[Music]
have you ever felt stressed burned out
anxious or sad me too during these times
it can be challenging to figure out how
to get out of it
but it does not have to be this way and
that is why we created this course to
share with you science driven skills
that will Empower you to build mental
strength when you bring screams no
matter what I'll fail you'll be able to
rely on exploring your thoughts to shift
your perspective and arrived at a more
balanced view of the world to jumpstart
your batteries you'll be able to charge
up ensuring you feel more energized if
anxiety threatens you kidnap your day
you'll learn how to observe and stop
your racing Mind through observing your
thoughts emotions and behavior cycle
because life can be scary we'll teach
you how to rely on science to face your
fears
and when you find yourself between two
tough options will help you to problem
solve
so you might be wondering who should
take this course the reality is we
designed this course for everyone
because these skills here have been
tested across populations across age
ranges around the globe but my hope is
that everyone can rely on the skills to
change the trajectory of their life one
little step at a time we want you to
become your most resilient self and this
course will help you do just that
foreign